I'm a relationship builder when you
think of a relationship builder don't
you just automatically think architect
probably that that's because most people
think architects design buildings and
cities but well we really design our
relationships because cities are about
people they're places where people come
together for all kinds of exchange and
besides skylines are highly specific
urban habitats with their own insects
plants and animals and even their own
weather but today urban habitats are out
of balance
climate change together with political
and economic troubles are having an
impact they're adding up and stressing
out cities and us the people who live in
them for me the field of ecology has
provided important insight because the
colleges don't just look at individual
species on their own they look at the
relationships between living things and
their environment they look at how all
the diverse parts of the ecosystem are
interconnected and it's actually this
balance this web of life that sustains
life my team and I have been applying
insights from ecology to architecture to
see how physical space can help build
stronger relationships the projects I'm
going to show you today use the idea of
building relationships as the key driver
for design here's an example of what I
mean recently we were asked to design a
Center for social justice leadership
called the arcus Center they asked us
for a building that could break down
traditional barriers between different
groups and in doing so create
possibilities for meaningful
conversations around social justice the
students wanted a place for cultural
exchange they thought a place for
preparing food together could do that
and they wanted to be welcoming to the
outside community they thought a
fireplace could draw people in and help
start conversations and everybody wanted
the work of social justice to be visible
to the outside world
it really wasn't a precedent for this
kind of space so we looked around the
globe and we found examples of community
meeting houses and community meeting
houses are places where there's very
specific relationships between people
like this one in Mali where the elders
gather the low roof keeps everybody
seated and at equal eye level
it's very egalitarian I mean you can't
stand up and take over the meeting you'd
actually bump your hat in meeting houses
there's always a central space where you
can sit around a circle and see each
other so we designed a space just like
that right in the middle of the arcus
Center and we anchored it with a
fireplace in a kitchen it's pretty hard
to get a kitchen and fireplace in a
building like this with the building
codes but it was so important to the
concept we got it done and now the
central space works for big social
gatherings and a place to meet
one-on-one for the very first time it's
almost like this three-way intersection
that encourages bumping into people and
starting a conversation and now you can
always pass the kitchen and whew
something going on you can sit by the
fireplace and share stories you can
study together in big groups or in small
ones because the architecture sets up
these opportunities even the
construction is about building
relationships it's made of cordwood
masonry which is using logs the way that
you would use bricks it's super low-tech
and easy to do and anyone can do it and
that's the entire point the act of
making is a social activity and it's
good for the planet too the trees absorb
carbon when they were growing up and
they gave off oxygen and now that carbon
is trapped inside the walls and it's not
being released into the atmosphere so
that making the walls is equivalent to
taking cars right off the road we chose
the building method because it connects
people to each other and to the
environment but is it working is it
creating relationships and nurturing
them how can we know well more and more
people are coming here for one and as a
result of the fireside chats and a full
calendar of programming people are
applying for the arcus
Fellowship's in fact applications have
increased tenfold for the arcus
fellowship since the building opened
it's working it's bringing people
together so I've shown how architecture
can connect people on this kind of
horizontal campus scale but we wondered
if social relationships could be scaled
up or rather upward in tall buildings
tall buildings don't necessarily lend
themself to being social buildings they
can seem isolating and inward you might
only see people in those awkward
elevator wrecks but in several major
cities though I've been designing tall
buildings that are based on creating
relationships between people this is
aqua it's a residential high-rise in
Chicago aimed at young urban
professionals and empty nesters many of
them new to the city with over 700
apartments we wanted to see if we could
use architecture to help people get to
know their neighbors even when their
homes are organized in the vertical
dimension so we invented a way to use
balconies as the new social connectors
these shapes of the floor slabs vary
slightly and they transition as you go
up the tower and the result of this is
that you can actually see people from
your balcony the balconies are missed
registered you can lean over your
balcony and say hey just like you would
across the backyard and to make the
balconies more comfortable for a longer
period of time during the year we
studied the wind with digital
simulations so the effect of the balcony
shapes breaks up the wind and confuses
the wind and makes the balconies more
comfortable and less windy and now just
by being able to go outside on your
balcony around the third floor of roof
terrace you can be connected to the
outdoors even when you're way above the
ground plane so the building X to create
community within the building and the
city at the same time it's working and
people are starting to meet each other
on the building surface and we've heard
they even start to get together as
couple but besides romantic
relationships the building has a
positive social effect on the community
as evidenced by people starting groups
together and starting big projects
together like this organic community
guarding on the building's roof terrace
so I've shown how tall buildings can be
social connectors but what about public
architecture how can we create better
social cohesion in public buildings and
civic spaces and why is it important
public architecture is just not as
successful if it comes from the top down
about 15 years ago in Chicago they
started to replace old police stations
and they built this identical model all
over the city and even though they had
good intentions of treating all
neighborhoods equally the communities
didn't feel invested in the process or
feel a sense of ownership of these
buildings it was equality in the sense
that everybody gets the same police
station but it wasn't equity in the
sense that's responding to each
community's individual needs and equity
is the key issue here you know in in my
field there's a debate about whether
architecture can even do anything to
improve social relationships but I
believe that we need architecture and
every tool in our toolkit to improve
these relationships and US policy
reforms have been recommended - in order
to rebuild trust but my team and I
wondered if design and a more inclusive
design process could help add something
positive to this policy conversation we
asked ourselves
can design help rebuild trust so we
reached out to community members and
police officers in North Lawndale it's a
neighborhood in Chicago where the police
station is perceived as a scary fortress
surrounded by a parking lot in North
Lawndale people are afraid of police and
of going anywhere near the police
station even to report a crime
so we organized this brainstorming
session with both groups participating
and we came up with this whole new idea
for the police station it's called
polish station and polis is a Greek word
that means a place with a sense of
community it's based on the idea that if
you can increase opportunities for
positive social interactions between
police and fuey
members you can rebuild that
relationship and activate the
neighborhood at the same time instead of
the police station as a scary fortress
you get highly active spaces on the
public side of the station places a
spark conversation like a barbershop a
coffee shop or sports courts as well
both cops and kids that they love sports
these insights they came directly from
the community members and the police
officers themselves and as designers our
role is just to connect the dots and
suggest the first step so with the help
of the city and the parks we were able
to raise funds and design and build a
half court right on the police station
parking lot it's a start but is it
rebuilding trust with people in North
Lawndale say that kids are using the
courts every day and then they even
organize tournaments like this one shown
here and once in a while an officer
joins in but now they even have best
clothes inside the station that kids can
borrow and recently they've asked us to
expand the courts and build a park on
the site and parents report something
astonishing before there was fear of
going anywhere near the station and now
they say there's a sense that the court
is safer than other courts nearby and
they prefer their kids to play here so
maybe in the future on the public side
of the station you might be able to drop
in for a haircut at the barbershop or
reserves a community room for a birthday
party a renew your drivers license are
getting money out of an ATM it can be a
place for neighbors to meet each other
and to get to know the officers and vice
versa this is not a utopian fantasy it's
about how do you design to rebuild trust
trusting relationships you know every
city has parks libraries schools and
other public buildings that have the
potential to be reimagined as social
connectors but reimagining the buildings
for the future is going to require
engaging the people who live there
engaging the public can be intimidating
and I felt that too but maybe that's
because in our case
to school we don't really learn how to
engage the public in the active design
we're taught to defend our design
against criticism but I think that can
change too so if we can focus the design
mind on creating positive reinforcing
relationships in architecture and
through architecture I believe we can do
much more than create individual
buildings we can reduce the stress and
the polarization in our urban habitat we
can create relationships we can help
study this planet we all share see
architects really are relationship
builders thank you
[Applause]